on this sunday night
the pandemics path through one
population
why doctors believe south asians are
getting covet 19 at a higher rate
than other canadians even if you're
following all the rules
it's very difficult to isolate in these
circumstances
how the community needs to protect
itself the atlantic bubble
why those provinces insist it's still
working despite new cases
and the urgent attention needed for kids
mental health
during this pandemic these are treatable
and they are preventable
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us in the midst of one of the most
celebrated festivals around the world
there's concern we'll see another search
of cova 19
across this country the south asian
festival of diwali has long been a worry
for health experts here
the areas that host the biggest
celebrations in canada
happen to be among the worst hit by
coveted 19.
as mike delay reports leading experts
say the cultural connection
thought to protect these communities may
be the ones that hurt them
there's nothing subtle about diwali it's
big bright
and crowded and to celebrate in canada
the hot spots are always surrey bc and
brampton ontario
which coincidentally are the areas most
responsible for feeding covid19 growth
in their respective provinces
to say brampton officials were worried
would be an understatement
they pleaded for restraint and for the
most part that's what they got the
toronto suburb has over 100 places of
worship
yet police were called to only one where
roughly 300 people had gathered in a
parking lot
the lineup was too big but they were
cooperative
they worked with bylaw and pillar police
to disperse the crowd
they shut down on their own only one
ticket was issued
leaving officers time to crack down on
illegal fireworks
the concern about large gatherings is
well founded
last week peel region which includes
brampton saw its positivity rate hit 10
percent
and that's not a coincidence according
to two infectious disease specialists
who say their community is defined by a
culture of large gatherings
multi-generational households and jobs
that are often essential services
you sometimes have up to 10 12 sometimes
even 14 people living under one roof
even if you're following all the rules
it's very difficult to
isolate in these circumstances that acts
as an amplifying
type of feature in fact while south
asians account for about a third of the
population of peel
they also account for nearly half of its
covid19 cases
there are particular needs to this
community it is driving a lot of what we
see in some of our hot spots in
british columbia in ontario one of the
biggest issues is where to quarantine
it's just impossible with big households
ontario health officials seem to have
clued into that
and are now setting up a quarantine
hotel to get positive cases out of their
homes
finally we're starting to get some help
we've got two new testing centers from
the province
we've got 70 new staff from from the
province for peel public health for
case management and
case trackers it's a start but will it
be enough to flatten the surging wave
of coveted cases microlake global news
toronto
here's a look at the pandemic situation
across the country bc
is not reporting today but there were
991 recorded in alberta
saskatchewan reported 181 new cases
manitoba broke its daily record with 494
new cases
ontario and quebec are both reporting
over a thousand new cases
there were 10 new infections reported in
nunavut before today
there had been just eight cases in total
in the territory
since the start of the pandemic and
there are new cases cropping up in
atlantic canada
three in new brunswick two in nova
scotia and two
in newfoundland and labrador the four
atlantic provinces have fared much
better than much of the country in the
fight against covid19
the so-called atlantic bubble allows
free movement within the region
while putting restrictions on people
entering from other parts of canada
as ross lord explains while other
provinces have fought against similar
measures
atlantic canadians have little desire to
see the bubble popped
with other parts of canada failing to
control covet 19
atlanta canada's glistening success has
become even more phenomenal
washing my hands making sure they're
clean and my house keeping that clean
i'm trying to stay away from crowds i
feel like in the maritimes we've got
like a good sense of community and like
really like an understanding and caring
for other people outside of just like
your immediate circle
so i think that that has to do with it a
lot as well just staying within my
little family bubble
trying not to associate with too many
people that i don't
don't know the atlantic provinces do
have new cases
but on any given day the region's total
is in single
digits compared to the rest of canada
the gap
is staggering manitoba whose population
is only slightly higher than nova
scotia's
reported nearly 31 cases per 100
thousand people
over a seven day period that includes
saturday that's the highest rate in
canada
many other provinces are not doing much
better between 19.5
and 10 cases per 100 thousand at the
bottom of the list
and loving it are nova scotia and the
other atlantic provinces
with 0.3 cases or lower
there's a growing number of alerts about
possible exposures
but still no clusters of covet 19.
but with the virus sweeping through the
rest of canada infectious disease
specialists urge nova scotians
not to become complacent we know what
works here
it's distance hand washing and masking
and now is the time for us
to all contribute a little bit by
tightening our bubbles a little bit
or we will end up with a bunch of
outbreaks and we will head in the wrong
direction as quickly as manitoba did
skeptics
suggest protective measures like strict
self-isolation rules
for everyone entering the atlantic
bubble are discouraging air travelers
and stifling the economy
an airline industry group says adopting
rapid covet 19 tests at airports would
reverse the decline
but with most cases traced to travel
nova scotia health authorities are
content to leave well enough alone
in fact chief medical officer robert
strang is asking students
studying outside the atlantic region to
stay away for the christmas holidays
ross lord global news halifax
in the united states more than 11
million people have been infected with
kova 19 but president donald trump's
focus is fixed on the legal battle over
the election he lost
today trump officially acknowledged that
joe biden won
but still says he will not concede
claiming the vote was
rigged tonight pressure is growing on
trump to accept biden as the
president-elect
and begin a peaceful transition jennifer
johnson reports
pro-trump supporters taking to the
streets in several u.s cities
tensions rose in washington leading to
over 20 arrests the demonstrators
repeating president donald trump's
baseless claim
that the election was rigged the vote
has not been declared that no
there is no president-elect it's all a
lie
the trump team keeps filing lawsuits in
an attempt to reverse ballot counts
already several cases have been
dismissed
president trump remains defiant on
twitter saying i concede nothing we have
a long way to go
this was a rigged election while earlier
writing that joe biden had one
donald trump's twitter feed doesn't make
joe biden president or not president the
american people did that what we really
want to see this week is the general
services administration
issue that ascertainment that would
allow president-elect biden to start
getting daily intelligence briefings
and both the incoming and outcoming
administrations to work together on the
covet 19 pandemic
and administering a future vaccine it's
almost like passing a baton in a race
you don't want to stop and then give it
to somebody you want to just essentially
keep going that's what
transition is the u.s has now surpassed
11 million coven 19
infections at least 25 states are
reporting record hospitalizations
and several state leaders have again
ordered partial shutdowns
and travel bans you must physically
distance when you cannot physically
distance
everybody needs to wear a mask in public
spaces that's absolutely critically
important they do work
the biden team says it's getting
pressure from governors for a nationwide
plan to stop the spread
my state's surrounded by four other
states and they all have different
recommendations
that by itself is what we're talking
about standardizing how we're all going
to approach this
president-elect biden will be meeting
with his covet 19 experts
and transition team all this week with
or without a formal concession from
president trump
today mexico topped one million cases of
coven 19 with close to a hundred
thousand
deaths that country has the world's
fourth highest death toll
after the united states brazil and india
critics say the infections are rising
because the government failed to impose
safety measures like lockdowns wearing
masks in public
testing and contact tracing
in france members of the catholic
community are demanding the government
relax new restrictions that include a
ban on religious services
france has more cases than any other
country in europe
new data released on friday by francis
health ministries shows
infections and hospital admissions have
fallen sharply
since the new measures were ruled out
the united nations is expecting the
number of people fleeing the conflict in
northern ethiopia to rise
exponentially as violence escalates the
un's high commission for refugees is
raising concerns
about the impact of refugees fleeing the
deteriorating situation
into neighboring sudan 20 000 people is
the size of a small town
moving across a border in four days they
were not prepared for
such a large influx of people
in this way tigre the center of the
conflict is an area about the size of
austria it was previously seen as a safe
haven for nearly a hundred thousand
refugees from other countries
the world agency says it's had to reduce
what services it can provide because
access to the region has been cut off
they are also increasingly at risk now
so we're faced with a possibility that
that refugees may also become internally
displaced which is for us really the
worst case scenario
overall there's nearly eight hundred
thousand refugees in ethiopia so for
for as it is a concern if this conflict
escalates and expands beyond the borders
of tigre as well
ethiopia's prime minister launched an
offensive integrate
earlier this month after security forces
loyal to the regional government
attacked an ethiopian national defense
base
both sides have been accused of carrying
out atrocities against civilians
15 asia pacific nations have formed the
world's largest free trade pact
the china-backed deal was signed on the
sidelines
of the asean summit held virtually from
vietnam this year
the partnership is made up of 10
southeast asian nations
as well as china japan south korea
australia
and new zealand it aims to lower tariffs
across the region and spur recovery from
the pandemic
this agreement signifies that our region
which has been the most
economically dynamic region of the world
in recent decades
is still committed to openness and to
trade
and that we will use that as a platform
and a springboard for recovery in the
post-covert era
members of the partnership make up
nearly a third of the world's population
and account for almost 30 percent
of the global gross domestic product
coming up
sounding the alarm on the pandemic's
impact on the mental health
of children
a new study is ringing alarm bells about
the impact of the pandemic on the mental
health
of children british columbia's
children's watchdog and researchers at
simon fraser university
found a pattern in previous public
health crises
as nadia stewart explains if the medical
system doesn't deal with it now
there will be consequences later
we've been saying for a long time that
the there's an inadequate child and
youth mental health
service system in an effort to better
understand
just how the pandemic is affecting the
mental health of children and youth
british colombia's representative four
children and youth
teamed up with researchers from simon
fraser university
recall sars in h1n1 there were studies
done on the impact on children
including children who had to be
isolated or quarantined and
what happened to them add to that
research on the impact
natural disasters have on children and
it paints a troubling picture of how
much their mental health
requires urgent attention in looking at
those past studies we were able to put
together
data really clearly showing that we can
expect to
see significant increases in
certain mental health problems for
children one study involving 369 north
american children affected by sars in
h1n1
found 30 percent exceeded the clinical
threshold for post-traumatic stress
symptoms
compared to just 1.1 percent for
children
who did not have these experiences about
33 percent of kids who'd been through
quarantine began using mental health
services
a much higher number than the 6.8
percent of children
and youth who were not in quarantine is
it mostly
social is it mostly psychiatric
is it functional in september dr quindon
also set out to better understand the
pandemic's impact on kids
while we await those findings what is
already clear is the need for more
support
especially since what was there
pre-pandemic was inadequate
children particularly those of asian and
indigenous descent facing racism
are being disproportionately affected
charlesworth says the data will help as
she makes the case
for more funding and targeted solutions
this research is very helpful to us
in terms of understanding not only the
scope or the magnitude of the challenge
but also what are the kinds of things
that would be effective because these
are treatable and they are preventable
nadia stewart global news vancouver
still ahead the fight for a fig tree
will explain
[Music]
you're watching global national
typhoon vamco has made landfall in
vietnam
although the storm is weakening there is
still a threat of flooding and
landslides
the government has evacuation plans in
place for roughly 468 thousand people
the typhoon has already done damage to
the philippines at least 67 people have
died there and the death toll is
expected to rise
as rescue crews continue their search
for dozens of people missing
the system packed winds that reached
kilometers an hour
torrential rain has triggered widespread
flooding
peru's interim president has resigned
six days after being sworn in
the country's political parties demanded
manuel mourinho step
down over the protests that have gripped
that country
thousands in peru have been staging some
of the country's largest demonstrations
in decades
but they've been marred by clashes with
police and two protesters were killed at
the hands of officers
a week ago the previous president martin
vizcarra
quit over allegations of bribery which
he denies
environmentalists in kenya are
celebrating tonight after saving
a century-old fig tree it lives in the
heart of the country's capital and was
scheduled to be removed to make way for
a highway
fig trees are important in kenya and
locals believe this particular tree
has sacred powers crystal gomencing
reports
it's a green victory this leafy towering
beacon in a busy commercial area in
nairobi
is staying put this particular fig tree
is just a symbol of the bigger picture
of what we're asking for
we want a green and clean city a green
and clean kenya
that is also climate resilient and this
means that we cannot afford to sacrifice
our green spaces for anything
including development the nearly 100
year old fig tree was slated to be
removed to make way for a new
multi-million dollar infrastructure
project
a four-lane highway built by china many
other trees were ripped from the ground
to make way for the expressway
but the fight for this one united the
community
[Music]
marches were organized and participants
loudly voiced their opposition to
uprooting the beloved tree more vocal
opposition was launched by local tribal
elders
who cited the tree's cultural and
spiritual history
this tree why we used to keep it
it used to be there because we went for
prayers there
there was a suggestion that the
four-story tall tree could be relocated
but many said that that plan was
questionable
because the tree might not be able to
survive
activists also launched a legal
challenge against the kenyan
environmental regulator for approving
the entire construction project
citing concerns over pollution and a
lack of green space in the sprawling
city
despite the challenge being before the
courts construction continued
but now after a year-long campaign
advocates got the news they had been
working for
on behalf of his excellency the
president
nms will issue a declaration
of conservation for this tree
for this iconic tree this decision today
gives me hope that activism works when
it comes to
protecting our environment and our green
spaces not only will the tree be
preserved for future generations it'll
stand as a national symbol of
environmental conservation
one that will spur on advocates as they
work to preserve
as much as the natural environment as
possible
crystal gamansen global news london
up next brittle star offers his two
cents on the covet conspiracy theories
a belgian bred racing pigeon set a world
record
as the most expensive ever auctioned off
new kim is her name and she sold for
nearly 2.5
million dollars a wealthy fan from china
paid that price
it shows the hobby that was once
identified with working-class men in
western europe
is now being taken over by elites
you've likely seen it on social media
the false claims that covet 19
is just a hoax meant to curtail people's
freedoms
but millions of people have been
infected worldwide and over a million
have died
now canadian artist stuart reynolds
better known online as brittlestar
has something to say about those who
think this virus is a sham
it's a hoax and they they expect us to
just
go along with it something you can't
even see
something so small that it can get
pretty much everywhere
but somehow not licking door handles can
protect you
even if they look perfectly clean give
me a break
this is all a hoax put together by big
science who are probably being paid off
by
big doorknob and sleazy handrail
no deep state plan is going to stop me
and my family from licking public
handrails
this is what coveted conspiracy bonkos
sound like to me
for some reason they have chosen this
pandemic as one of the times they've
turned to science with a raised eyebrow
and said
i don't believe you because i can't
understand it and i don't care what the
consequences are
this which has so far only asked people
to either stay home
or wear a mask when you need to and
stand far enough apart you can't smell
each other
the latter i'd imagine being a blessing
for some people the people who claim
it's a hoax
baffle me a hoax to what end vaccine
makers
so they'll let millions of potential
customers die
big government so they can destroy the
economy and have less power
i get it science is tricky
i still can't quite figure out how a 737
which weighs over 80 000 kilograms
can somehow fly but you know what
doesn't matter that i don't know how it
works scientists and other smart people
have figured that out for me
i'm also not entirely sure how a toaster
works
but that's more on me than anything else
but if science tells me
not to lick handrails or doorknobs or
i'll get sick
i won't lick handrails or doorknobs
you don't even need to believe in
science science doesn't require your
belief it's not santa
sleigh you don't even need to be as
smart as a scientist
you just need to be smart enough to know
you should listen to them
and that was brittle star and that is
global national for this sunday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
this silver fox caught on camera near
yellowknife
we'd love to see your part of this
country so email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]